Jeff D'Andria: So, yeah, let's… I just want to kind of set the table, A little bit with…
Jeff D'Andria: Honestly, what I'll be driving toward is the couple things that we're gonna try, those adjustments. I'd love to give you a sense of why those are…
Jeff D'Andria: important. So what's the why? So… let's talk about this empathy for the recruiter. I feel like empathy is, like, a strong word.
Jeff D'Andria: Especially for someone we don't know. But that is what we're talking about, but maybe another way of saying it is something like.
Jeff D'Andria: Let's just, like, get into the psychology of a recruiter a little bit.
Jeff D'Andria: And what matters to them.
Sathya Narayanan: Hey, Jeff, like, are you supposed to be in slide 3 or something?
Sathya Narayanan: Is it… am I seeing slide 3 as the agenda you're talking about?
Jeff D'Andria: Do you see psychology of a recruiter?
Sathya Narayanan: No, we are looking at the… at least I am seeing only the first slide.
Nancy Rios: Yeah, same here.
Sathya Narayanan: Now I can see the psychology of a recruiter.
Nancy Rios: neat.
Jeff D'Andria: Maybe that's better.
Sathya Narayanan: Okay, yeah.
Jeff D'Andria: There it goes.
Jeff D'Andria: You…
Jeff D'Andria: Yeah, so let's go from empathy to really, like, calling it something else, like the psychology of a recruiter, and let's get into their head.
Jeff D'Andria: So, this is… And I'm literally…
Jeff D'Andria: stole this, he just sent us our… the slide deck, our contact at Ashby from an hour ago.
Jeff D'Andria: this is, like, the process that we're trying to break into, if our resume works, right? Recruiter screen, get to the hiring manager, which would be, like, your future manager that makes that kind of ultimate decision.
Jeff D'Andria: And everything else, you know, that's the process. But to get to there, I really wanted to quickly, like, double-click on this recruiter.
Jeff D'Andria: Peace, and more importantly, like.
Jeff D'Andria: I'm gonna try and share my screen to make sure… make this… do you see the resume?
Jeff D'Andria: Satya?
Jeff D'Andria: Yeah, okay.
Jeff D'Andria: So this is the piece. To get into that process, your resume has to be, you know.
Jeff D'Andria: I'll just call it… I put them on that first slide, like, breaking the pattern, right? And I say that because I think
Jeff D'Andria: Getting into the psychology of a recruiter.
Jeff D'Andria: One thing that I just want to impart is there's a pattern that they're using. Yeah.
Sathya Narayanan: I think, like, the text is a little unclear to see. Can you maybe go into, view, like, kind of make the slideshow? Yeah, click on slideshow so that it is…
Sathya Narayanan: Whether it'll make it full screen and it'll be easier, because the resume is a little difficult to see.
Jeff D'Andria: Hmm.
Jeff D'Andria: Let me see if this will work…
Sathya Narayanan: Yeah.
Sathya Narayanan: I think this is better.
Jeff D'Andria: Okay. Alright, so…
Jeff D'Andria: There is a… there is a pattern that, recruiters are used to saying yes to.
Jeff D'Andria: Just…
Jeff D'Andria: take my word for it. They probably aren't even aware that they just start trending toward a yes, and this was actually… we brought in the head of technical recruiting from Yelp to speak to the students a couple years ago, and they said that themselves, that
Jeff D'Andria: Your job as a candidate is to fit the pattern
Jeff D'Andria: And then, once you fit the pattern, which this is a resume style, which, Nancy, feel free to share the link with the students, if you don't mind, if they don't have this yet.
Jeff D'Andria: I've gotten feedback, one I pulled from
Jeff D'Andria: all my experiences to, like, what was the yes resume, and then I went to recruiters over at Spotify, at Twitch.
Jeff D'Andria: At Microsoft, and got their feedback, like, help me perfect, like, what's a good resume look like? And that's what you're looking at now. So one, if you're looking to try different styles, this is one that has worked. Helped many, many students get jobs with this.
Jeff D'Andria: So… This is the pattern, a pattern, that they're used to saying yes to. Now, within this pattern.
Jeff D'Andria: I would argue… so, concept number one, adjustment number one.
Jeff D'Andria: You probably really only have the attention of a recruiter
Jeff D'Andria: Can I just put it out to the group?
Jeff D'Andria: How long do you think, how many seconds?
Jeff D'Andria: minutes? Do you think, before they already kind of start saying, I…
Jeff D'Andria: no or yes? Is this person gonna get an interview?
Jeff D'Andria: Someone… Feel free to come off the mic and just throw out some numbers.
Armando Vega: Maybe 3 to 5 seconds.
Jeff D'Andria: Yeah.
Dornet Gray: 20… 20 seconds?
Jeff D'Andria: 20 seconds, you know?
Keidra Floyd: Yeah, I agree, maybe, like, 5 seconds.
Jeff D'Andria: Yeah.
Jeff D'Andria: Yeah, I think, I think that 3 to 5 second range is, is, is solid.
Jeff D'Andria: I'd say it's right in there, maybe even less. And so…
Jeff D'Andria: Again, you have one shot at a first impression, and so concept number one.
Jeff D'Andria: I think you re… like, the amount of time that they start… they might read the rest of the resume, but they're kind of already trending toward a hard yes, no.
Jeff D'Andria: Right away, and then as you read further down, you're kind of like, just like, okay, this person's kind of a no already. Alright, but anything gonna… any back-page thriller stuff here?
Jeff D'Andria: So you really have their full attention right here.
Jeff D'Andria: Right in the beginning.
Jeff D'Andria: Right? And that's, like, if they're on a full stomach and they're not hungry, or is it Friday at 4.30? Like, are they even, like, excited right now about to be at work?
Jeff D'Andria: Maybe not? So, like…
Jeff D'Andria: We really have to use this top, kind of, one-third of real estate on the resume, and gosh, like, almost, like, try to be a yes just right there.
Jeff D'Andria: So that's gonna be something we'll work on today, is that top third of the resume, and maximizing that moment of having their neutral, full, hopefully full attention right there. Best shot at it.